Is it okay to change the length of time under the dwell number if we want to extend the heli time?
Yes, it's funny because I've been using right for gosh 20 plus years 25 years
It's only the second time I've gotten this question in the first time I got this question was like three weeks ago
so
It tells me that our patients are getting smarter. That's what tells me
So yes, so the dwell time in the program itself. So when you're looking at the program running
Where it says the different codes in the program or you could see it says things like pulse and dwell and
That those are commands under the dwell it might say 180 that means it's gonna dwell on the following frequencies
Until the dwell is changed or a hundred and eighty seconds each frequency if you wanted to change the length of the time
Let's say the program was an hour long program and you wanted to make it a two hour program
Well, you could play with it and change the dwell on it and hit rub and it's like oh now it's an hour and a half
Well, then up the dwell again hit run. Oh, there. It's two hours
Then you could hit save and now you save that program with that different dwell
Really negative of you playing with it is
You do risk messy to them. So but if you feel confident in
Just changing the dwell
You're not gonna hurt anything and if you don't hit save
You you know, you and you go out of the program and go back in it
It wouldn't have been saved so we'll be back to the original program
It would only change the program if you hit save
So if you hit dwell and you change the dwell
On a program and then you hit run and oh, that's the perfect time for me because I you know, whatever that's the time you want
Then I would just hit save and now you'll have that program saved on the time
So yes, you can do that